buckle up everybody Michael Irvin's in
town henna fell Network analyst and the
whole thing it was so nice seeing you
were rich together - yeah back together
again yeah no I was with you guys early
early on over at the 4-letter network
over there you know and and watch you
guys back together again it's just great
you both have your own show I don't mind
imma tell her a rich one day I had your
head on rich you know cuz you gave me
that black hat with the Dan Patrick show
yeah you know what I had on that day
coming through the airport you know hat
down and I said Dan Patrick got walked
there rich was like did you just sit
next to me with a dead every year we
have you on at the Superbowl
there's always not I don't know if it's
drama but there are memories that we
have real fun stuff real fun time
orleans was one of the one of our faith
it rained so hard in New Orleans and
Michael sat down and all of a sudden our
ceiling started to collapse a it was
like that was on his - you didn't rain
that hard that the ceiling was coming
down on ya we've had so far dead I'm
gonna tell you when i lo was the one in
Jacksonville I think it was Jacksonville
when we went with early we got there
early early in the week and we were
there for a nicely that despite had a
great little spot nice function and it
was a bright light nice crowd and then
showed and we all guess we decided to go
back to that spot later on in the week
and boy it was a real dark cloud
[Laughter]
the crowd was a little lighter it was
like crowd we had a great time in this
bar so we go back let's go back and all
of a sudden we walk in with me you
oughta get street cred
you're with me I never left my side I
was like Mike you stay right here
it was like he was my seeing-eye dog I
was on for dear life
do not leaving and I mean you know in
there a level with when you hit the
brothers club you know this upscale
brothers club and their knees are not
off ski our brother club and this was
not is this the same bar we went into I
swear you walk in here you go that's not
the same bar you know what are you doing
who you with
and I'd be like I'm with Mike
we have Ice Ice Cube on when I said cube
I said how would it go if I went into
Compton he goes brother's got cable
you're cool Network 85 hours got
coverage this week more than that oh my
gosh you got eight and a half hours of
game day morning for the game the more
hours they building it's just what it is
again I don't want you to get in trouble
here now no more TV I'm good let's come
back welcome back with Michael Irvin the
playmaker right after this in the Dan
Patrick show Michael Irvin the
playmakers with us and basically
starting their Super Bowl coverage when
he gets off it's eighty five hours of
Super Bowl coverage this week by the way
got one for you baby Cowboys have had
seven different Super Bowl MVPs all-time
most of any team in football there's
Chuck Holley and they gave it to the
losing team Chuck Haley played for the
Cowboys when they lost to the Colts
America's Team Roger Staubach Harvey
Martin Randy white Coe Troy Emmitt and
then Larry Brown your MVPs did you ever
think you deserved an MVP Mike Detroit
an MVP that you should have gotten no it
worked out I didn't hold up my end of
the bargain and a couple foot ways you
know we troy won MVP when we had the
Super Bowl in Pasadena he played at UCLA
we practiced at his field I told him it
we can't get to Pensacola so the closer
we got to Pensacola was that Lana and
Emma got MVP there that 31 Super Bowl
was in Miami what's in Miami that should
have been my Super Bowl MVP in Miami but
of course we go out in the championship
game in 94 and we spot them 21 points
and then D on a guy we just
about pass interference that you know
collared by I'm still bothered by that I
told you this I know I think about every
day of my life that play right there so
I should have gotten it in Miami and
then I thought I could have gotten it in
Arizona but they call back that
touchdown mm you know so so I think
about that every day - last round got my
MVP Larry Brown the O'Donnell helped
hand-delivered them don't take away
Larry's greatness by saying hello
darling wait wait you just wanted to
take away his great cuz I'm putting more
great Jerri says that he's got 80
catches in his in his body right now
yeah he said he could help believe that
I believe Jerry believes that I believe
he said that I don't believe he can
actually do it how many catches could
Jerry Rice get if he if he like I mean I
don't know how healthy today but good
Jerry Rice still play a chair rice key
you could probably get out there run a
hitch against some zone coverage where
everybody's off but you know anybody
that plays Jerry Rice right now it's
going jigging Jer is a phenomenal
competitor P I'm telling you guys right
now is phenomenal competitor still to
this day but any one of these young
quarterbacks they're going to get up on
him and press them and see how he can
try see if we can get a release and and
could you play now oh god no God no I
know people always say this is not
functional it just looks like this trust
me
it can't run one route me oh god no no
no no my body's not going for that
what's wrong with you and I unlike most
of these guys are like Jerry and tio and
and and and and Chad Ochocinco I'm at
peace with this I mean you got rings
Mike yeah I know it's over for me a Hall
of Fame jacket yeah and I got old age
just like they have that's why we're not
playing Jerry Jerry's the most decorated
wide receiver of all time the greatest
ever the greatest ever invariably uh-oh
I saw Tom Brady I don't see a greater
football player than Jerry Rice do you
have a problem with people saying
Brady's the greatest player of all time
no not anymore not anymore because
before it was Jerry Rice for me but but
as Brady keeps stacking up championships
the way he's doing it you can't argue
with the statement that he's the
greatest player of all times and you can
argue you can't possibly give me any
kind of argument that you knew a greater
coach Bill Belichick I know tell me
about even now in days what we're seeing
with Golden State because that's a
collection of great talent all together
and they're staying together Bill
Belichick has done this with numerous
different players and just continue to
put out the same thing he's just the
greatest ever and Tom Brady is the
greatest football player ever
we brought this up probably a little
less than two weeks ago that was Brady
if he wins his sixth title could you put
him in the category of most decorated
team athletes with Jordan in the last 30
years like would you have a different
sport obviously yeah you know and we're
not comparing athleticism we're
comparing results right right you can't
complain prepare athleticism know your
helpers we still see that picture of Tom
Brady had to come by but that's what
makes him great I always say this I
mention men on distance travel well you
saw that body there's no way you saw six
championships in that body you didn't
see much of anything in that body
but before hidden to produce what he has
produced and play at the level he has
played at it's incredible it's
incredible all of us living should
understand how blessed we are to be in
this moment while he's doing what he's
doing and in answer is I say yes to to
comparing him to Jordan in a sense and I
think what he's accomplished is much
more difficult you're talking about a
whole bunch of more people that you have
to stay in line with and stay here to to
get the win championships in football
then you're doing basketball
that's why LeBron James is going to
eight seven straight because one player
can almost get you in basketball doesn't
work that way in football but there's a
quarterback have to have a certain ego
and arrogance like be a jerk the you
know kind of I don't know that he has
to be a jerk but he has to I believe
have the ability to to lead and and and
not and not in any way feel like he has
to capitulate to others but which truly
ever a jerk
no he'll I don't call him a jerk but he
didn't capitulate either he would give
him he was he was running this show but
I say it out of respect that you kind of
have to be that guy who has to be a bad
guy or I'm gonna be the guy who says
Mike shut up you know no one in the
office of Lyman goes and complain to him
Michaels talking to my guy he doesn't
have to block that guy and March or Neil
somebody would say Michael you're not
gonna block him one time during this
game come on leave him alone leave him
alone you know so they'll go to Troy
they said be up here and Troy I'll pull
me what Tom what do you make of Dez
Bryant and his future in Dallas because
he's not a number one anymore can and
he's too expensive to be a number two
number three receiver you people your
people and I say you people in an
integrated way he's not just you Dan but
all the people and football we get a
hold of something sometimes and we're
like a dog with a bone right now this
Brian is the bone man let that go I
would do this a couple years ago with
all these cowboy fans when they were
winning we let DeMarco Mary go in stop
you don't find number one receivers
hanging off trees like leaves so what
you wanted to let dad's go who you gotta
replace them you don't find on this
easily and the Cowboys will be stupid
said why it's a bone for sports fans
it's because it's the Cowboys and we
expect dez to be better because he's
shown us he can be better
you got a great running game yeah he's
got a better you got a good quarterback
you got a great offensive line
jason witten to me it's tough for him to
still be your starting tight in in my
opinion yeah and I have a problem with
Dez Bryant getting paid that as a number
one guy then that what goes along with
that is you want your touches to prove
you're a number one guy then you got
issues they're mine and you just said it
you know you know that there's Bryant
you've seen what Dez Bryant could do
you've seen there's Bryan put up 16
touchdowns in a season now he has a new
quarterback who we have just given the
old man tag - it's like Doc has been
around forever already playing football
and it's just a second year he just
finished his second year and and Dez has
to bring that alone Tony Romo with
something different and Tony and I would
talk about this sometimes you know Tony
knew you know just how to handle a
team's personality he said Mike I would
just throw sometimes go all free just to
make sure I get the ball to death
because I wanted this positive energy I
wanted this positive energy these are
things that a young doc is going to
learn the process down the road but I'm
telling you right now guys back up back
up on 88 right now and trust me trust me
give it time
this was a tough year for the Dallas
Cowboys nobody's talking about the thing
that hung over their head o year long it
was a tough year
I said let's reload shoot one more shot
next year things don't go down then you
start making change all right final
minute tell me how Philadelphia wins
defense if the defense plays like it's
been playing lately it's been incredible
I mean it's incredible you know I'm
gonna tell you guys something
you know defensively they've talked
amongst each other amongst themselves
and you know they're not going to tell
Nick Fulton it we don't think you can
get it done they all say cold word
because I remember those cold words you
know when Troy wasn't playing and and
and Charles Hayter will come and say man
we're gonna be alright I said we'll be
all right we're gonna be all right you
know I'm alright don't worry about what
good he says so you said we need a hold
on the 14th
so that's the code is going on and the
defense you know they're like we holding
on the 40 and they have been holding
everybody under that so they're
basically saying Nick don't mess this up
you know go get us 40 17 or 17 win a
game but Nick put up some points last
week against Minnesota so as long as
they keep that same mentality no defense
they got ash okay if I said to you right
now the Eagles score 24 points do they
win the game huh Tom Brady's not
guaranteed it's not guaranteed good part
Mike it's just it's not guaranteed
I'm Guinea just playing kilt social
media because I see I rather the Eagles
win instead of the Patriots winning they
care about is that the Eagles applauding
when you're down you're paralyzed on
that turf yeah my thoughts were a whole
lot of places were like man God ain't
gonna know these lot of things down here
or never work again yeah and Sunday
eight and a half hour edition of NFL
gameday morning and 85 hours of live
Super Bowl coverage this week
[Music]
like thanks for stopping by well take a
break we'll close up shop here the Dan
Patrick show right after this for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]